all right I want nothing more than to
scream spoilers into my camera I'm not
gonna do it it's gonna be a spoiler free
review I might have to do a spoiler
video on this one I don't know if I'm
even motivated to yet but okay so
spoiler free review let's just do it
[Music]
dominated our faith so terminator dark
fate is the sixth Terminator movie
believe it's been six right they're all
forgettable after two one is we have
another attempt to make the true sequel
to Terminator 2 now James Cameron's
producing this one I have a couple of my
friends were like no I have faith and
I'm like I don't just fool me once shame
on you fool me twice shame on me
fool me three times you are The
Terminator franchise I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna hold my breath here's the plot
hold on to your butt's a machine has
been sent back through time to kill
somebody and if they kill them then the
future human beings don't have a leader
and of course the resistance in the
future sends someone here to protect her
on with the show we've been here a few
times before first of all I did enjoy
seeing Linda Hamilton reprise her role
of Sarah Connor mostly because there
were a couple of moments that led to
some touching moments with Sarah Connor
and I enjoyed that I didn't feel
fulfilled having her in the movie but
you know the movies not fulfilled
Gabriel Luna enjoy him as this evil
Terminator that is an endoskeleton but
has a liquid metal skin over it which of
course we've seen before
only they use this dude in a different
and very logical way the liquid metal
can come off the endoskeleton and form
into another hem and now they're taking
on two of them it makes a lot of sense
some like what why didn't that happen in
t3
okay good job terminator Dirk fate
that's a cool Terminator after that it's
an action movie now is it a good action
movie and that's where we start running
into roles not actually where we start
running into problems beginning of this
movie that was problems for me explore
video if I do one but [ __ ] that but in
terms of action movie I look at
Terminator right it's a very simple
premise this Terminator comes back
through time and it's just car chases
and gun shootouts cuz bullets will kill
somebody
it's a very intense movie because it's
still grounded in reality for a movie
about a machine from the future comes
back through time to kill somebody
Terminator 2 cranks it up a few notches
but still it's guns and explosions but
nothing's too terribly insane for a
movie about a liquid metal terminator
comes back through time to kill somebody
but now action movies always feel like
they have to crank it up a bunch of not
just like oh we got to make it more
intense we gotta have it bigger with
more explosions and when I'm watching
movies that do that it's just it pulls
me out of it I'm like
it's not perilous it doesn't feel
dangerous because it feels insane and
that's what this movie does there is a
scene it's not really a spoiler I'm just
telling you an action scene that happens
they may or may not be in a Humvee
tumbling side over side down a waterfall
over a dam and I was like she's
hamburger she's dead a rat movie over
that's what would happen it's just
bigger but it it's not intense because
it's [ __ ] insanity any of the biggest
thing I notice in here it isn't really a
terminator dark fate thing it's not new
it's actually been happening quite often
where they're like alright this is a new
thing it's created for a new generation
we don't want to rely on the past what
we do but we want to say that we don't
but we totally do this movie clearly
establishes now you don't need the
previous Terminator movies this is
terminator now but there are so many
moments in this movie that threw back to
the other Terminator movies I'm talking
there are shots in this movie where I'm
like that is from Terminator 2
Terminator 2 Terminator 3 there's one
thing where I was like that's from
Terminator 3 you're using that from
Terminator 3 either they're relying on
cheap nostalgia which they probably are
or for terminator they just don't have
any new ideas so they're just gonna
borrow from the other stuff this movie
has some good concepts and in the end
you you walk out of the movie going I
just feel like I've seen it before
whether it's your brain piecing together
the things in this movie they borrowed
from other Terminator movies fact is
it's just a mediocre Terminator movie
and quite frankly it still lends it to
Arnold's t800 being in this movie at all
is so ridiculous it's like porn writers
well not really the only thing getting
[ __ ] or the Terminator movies what I
mean by that is in porn
you know because gonna make a story
informed if you start using your brain
you're gonna be like that's a ridiculous
storyline but it's there
to get this [ __ ] person on screen
together with this [ __ ] person so
the thing good happen and that's what
this is this is ridiculous writing to
get Arnold Schwarzenegger on screen with
Linda Hamilton in a Terminator movie
because we're done with the old
Terminator movies we're done with the
old franchise we're moving on with this
new timeline this new Terminator
hopefully franchise but we still want
all the advantages that come from
nostalgia be honest anyhow [ __ ] it let's
just read it I'll say I'm not gonna
remember this movie in t-minus one day
they already forgot it shouldn't be a
franchise I've seen this argument online
and I completely agree
Hawaiian's Terminator franchise it's a
simple premise it's like robot from the
future comes back in time to kill
somebody and someone else or something
else from the future comes back to
protect that person unless it's a
Terminator movie that takes place in the
future which should have been cooler
than it was that's pretty much the plot
you're dealing with it doesn't lend
itself to being a franchise yeah if I
make a spoiler video for terminator
dark-faced it's gonna be me bitching
about like one thing for a few minutes
but it's my channel I was a terminator
dark fate have you seen it what did you
think about it or rank the Terminator
movies from best to worst so whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to say more
[Music]